- There's always a moment
where you're just doing
it 'cause you're doing it,
and then you kind of realize,
wait, is this something big?
Like this is something,
something is happening.
(bright upbeat music)
"The Gary Vee Audio Experience."
Vayner Nation, what's good?
It's me, Gary and I'm extremely excited,
especially for one of my
best, best, best, best friends
in college, Rob Muse,
who within the first 48 hours
of being at my Ida college,
I went to his dorm room to play Madden
and he put on Too Short
and he banged it heavy
and he was bringing that flavor.
So Muse the shows is for you.
E, Short thank you so much for being on,
as I was just telling E
before we started the show,
I was born in the Soviet Union
but I moved to Queens and
grew up in Jersey and I'm 45.
So what you two men
represent to me personally,
you know growing up and
being affected by hip hop.
And then especially in college where,
the friend I just mentioned Rob Muse.
I had friends that were
really deep into it
and the education went to a
whole different place of music
just outside of just New York for me,
one of my best friends
Dustin Bingham was from LA.
And we, when I think of you guys
it takes me to a real
special time in my life.
We'll get into that in a minute
but there's a whole different
thing that I wanna talk about,
which is, you know the
entrepreneurial journey
that I've been on watching
the entrepreneurship
that's come out of y'all is
also just been incredible.
And then just modern technology, you know,
and the culture and the brand building,
and obviously culminating
in the versus battle
for a lot of people.
But I just there's, I'm so
fucking busy these days.
So when things come
across my desk I'm like
will you do this podcast,
even real fancy, fancy people
I'm like, I just can't, I'm
too operating right now.
I'm too, too busy, but they didn't like
I read one word in the email,
they sent me about this
and I was like, confirmed,
get it done asap.
So gentlemen, thank you so much.
I truly say this for my soul.
You gentlemen are legends.
I'm honored.
I will look back at this, my whole life.
I'm gonna send the 80 clips of this
to all my boys I grew
up with, I'm real happy.
How are you?
- Thank you.
Thank you for having us, Gary.
- Of course for the small group of people
that don't know who you
are, E start us off.
Give everybody a little context of you.
A little 30, 45 second bios.
Same with you Short after
it, and we'll get into this.
- Hey everybody, what's going on.
I go by the name E-40,
real name Earl Stevens.
Came in the game 1988.
First album came out EP,
most valuable players
me and my family.
D-Shot, Suga T, B-Legit,
we became the Click a year later
and here I am now 2021.
Doing my thing you know what I'm saying?
Trying recording artists the
whole world, very legendary,
you know and my other legendary partner,
he right here by me,
so go ahead and identify
yourself Too Short.
- Yeah my name is Too Short
and you know for anybody
who never really knows me
I just say, regardless of, if
you could find that one thing
that identifies you to
me, you don't have to
I am ingrained in pop cultures, DNA.
I am very, you hear me coming
from 15 different angles
and whether it's my
voice or another voice,
and I'm just I've been there a long time
I've sold millions and
millions of records.
And man me and E-40 we
like homegrown Bay Area.
And just, you know,
we actually aren't just
rappers or artists.
We are two pioneers who
actually laid the foundation
for a entire region's hip hop existence.
- Let's talk about that Short
cause I fully see it that way.
And then I always think about
what's the foundation of the foundation.
- Mm-hmm yeah.
- Right, and so I want it, you know,
I had LL on the show
a couple of months ago
and just wanted to like
educate all the, you know
so many youngsters listened to this.
And I've been so happy
with what's been going on
and you know, Timbo knows got
like I just love that people
get reeducated or educated.
'Cause sometimes it's both.
- The Bay Area is lucky.
Let me give a little look a little bit.
- Please.
- Bay Area got lucky as fuck
because the Bay Area got
in the early infancy stages of hip hop.
It got Too Short, and it got E-40,
Todd Shaw and Earl Stevens.
These were two guys who
were, we just had a dream.
We wanted to get in, we
wanna get to the music
but we've fortunately is that right place
at the right time thing
40 standing there in the presence
of his uncle St. Charles,
who has the knowledge of
how to make and sell music.
I ended up in the presence of Dean Hodges
who's bartering all these
musicians and singers
and you know, studios and all these people
to satisfy his cursing of fantasy
of wanting to be in the music industry.
But he didn't have the talent
so he surrounded himself with it
and he learned the game
and he taught it to me.
He taught me how to make and sell records.
So at the same time,
we're getting the same sort of information
and getting ready to put it to work.
'Cause we're both talented me and E-40
we're about to put this knowledge to work.
But the beautiful part is,
we're not we didn't just
end up doing it for us.
We ended up doing it for
the whole fucking Bay Area.
And then we ended up almost like partners.
This is crazy.
- How did both of you individually,
when did your music journey career,
not career journey excuse me, start?
In the house what was being played?
What was grandma playing?
What was your best friend playing?
Like when I say earliest music impact
where do you go with
like, oh, I like this.
Where do both of you go, E?
- My goal from my mom
being in the church choir
and being surrounded
by just so much talent.
My aunties playing the
drums, aunties playing drums
playing the piano,
you know like naturally they
never took lessons or nothing.
They just all knew.
They all talented.
My uncles also, you know,
being there in my earlier
day, my mom and my dad divorce
but even so when I was younger,
my daddy he'd be in there.
You know 'cause he paint hell
a good, he paint cars off
and he held a talented and
my mom was so hella good.
So she was doing tire covers
for the vans back in the days
my daddy paints all the
vans and the crest.**
Just, when I stayed in the crest
and you know they have
band clubs with the CB's
and everything break a breaker, one, two
and all that stuff.
All they played him and my
mama, that's all they played
was like the old Jays, old players,
you know, the Isley Brothers,
you know just all like,
you know, even a lot of disco music
like Donna Summers Sisters.
- Yeah, how old are you?
- Who me?
- Yeah.
- I'm 53.
- Yes of course that's heavy influence,
disco you know, I'm 45.
Yeah, exactly I mean, that's linked
you know in and lingering out,
but like that's heavy influence.
- Yeah, oh yeah for sure.
And so, you know, it did, when I heard,
I'll just go fast forwarding
when I heard the Sugar Hill Gang in 1979.
I said, I wanted to be a rapper man.
- And flat out, is that flat
out, you heard Sugar Hill
and flat out, you said I'm be a rapper.
- Look at that (indistinct)
goofing around with it.
I got a, you know, I'm
putting that down to 88
like real official music in 88.
But I'm saying 79 I'm just
a little kid I'm only 11.
You know what I'm saying?
- But it hit you.
- You just skipped the marching
band, the band, band class.
- Oh man, thank you bro.
Oh, when I was in the fourth grade,
I signed up for the marching for the band.
So I told my mama, they say,
hey, cause I was in class
they was like, anybody who
wanna sign up for band?
You know, write your name on here
and we're gonna tell you what to get.
So they told me to go get that.
They put it, they gave me a little,
a little list to put in there that say
a drum pass, a drum, a music book
and some drums and two
pairs of drumsticks.
And so I took it to my mama
and I said I wanna be in band ma
you know what I'm saying?
She took me down to
Momma's Music in Vallejo.
You know what I'm saying?
And bought me the drums,
two pairs of drumsticks
a drum pad where you can
do the practice the word,
the ramp taps and all that.
You know what I'm saying?
Whatever you wanna call it, and it.
- So it was always there.
- Yeah, and I played the drums all the way
from the fourth grade, all
the way to the 12th, bro.
Like I didn't stop.
And you know that wasn't so
much at a cool thing to do.
I would just gained up I
played all sports, all that.
But that's fucking (indistinct).
- Gary, Gary, think about E-40
raps like a drummer drums.
- You know, it's funny, you were saying
I was sitting and I was
like that cadence come 100%,
it makes a ton of sense.
What about for you Short,
how did it like, like what did you
when did you get affected by music?
- So I think all of us kids who were like,
if you were anywhere in
that 70s, household vibe
like I don't care what color you were,
music was very like when records got big,
they just crossed over.
Like I play the hits of my childhood
and a white kid from the
summer goes those hits,
the hits from my childhood.
You know, we're kind of close in age.
It didn't matter.
Like a lot of songs when I was a kid,
I grew up in found out
that was a white guy
that was a Spanish guy.
And that was you know.
- Right when you actually
saw them on TV family.
- Yeah it like I would
have never (indistinct)
it was just music.
So I'm a little kid.
- And the Biggs.
- Oh yeah the Biggs they were cool
that was on the radio.
- They were just shit.
- Andy give.
- Come on that was a little crazy.
- Andy was most famous
person in (indistinct).
- And it turn out from that little movie
that they were fucking Australian
I didn't know that shit.
- (indistinct) calling (indistinct) out.
Don't do (indistinct) we
did know what was going on,
don't do that song.
- You were starting when
you saw they were white.
- Yeah, so the point I was making is,
it was the kind of break up
where songs were on the radio
songs from anywhere from the
temptations to rain drops,
keep falling on my head.
It was just music so I'm this little kid
who I live in a house where
they play the records.
They actually play there,
they purchase and play records.
And my house was my father's
from Jackson, Mississippi.
And my mother's from a small
town outside of New Orleans.
My house was last of Motown
before the kids had any say.
So it was a lot of Motown in the air.
A lot of that, Al green kind of soul
a lot of that, just in the air.
I had a auntie that we
used to spend a lot of time
at her house and she
took it a little further.
She'd be really like
some average white band
and some Funkadelic, you
know album covers that
we're looking at this shit
like this looks scary you know.
- She was really about music
and she gonna collect it.
- She's playing this shit though.
She's a little more
gangster, a little more.
They sitting in the kitchen
fucking shit playing Dominoes and cards.
And that's when company would come over
and the kids in my culture,
the kids just get told
shut the fuck up.
- On the (indistinct).
- Get your ass in the room.
- They in there you hear
all this shit, mother fucker
I'm laugh, even giggle,
laugh, comments, you get just.
- On the cards kick, who's
better at Spades E or Short?
- We haven't played Spades
I'd whop Short's ass at spade.
- I'm good at everything.
- (laughing) It like period.
- What I'm I asking like
ping pong and for Short pool.
(indistinct)
One thing I know for sure
I beat him in is Dominoes.
You can't fuck with me.
- Short.
- I'm a bowling expert too.
I never say this what
I say about Dominoes.
I never talk shit.
And I think that there's
a certain character
in domino player, that the
one who doesn't talk shit
and you bring that game.
I'm like, I don't try.
I never, I only talk shit
while I'm whooping your ass
I don't talk shit.
- I talk shit.
You gotta talk shit in
order to win Dominoes.
- I need to get to-
- So let me tell you about the music man
'cause it's very specific.
- Please.
- I traveled around kid
who gets sent to Louisiana for the summers
and you know spend the
summer with your cousins.
So I'm in this household,
my family's household
a lot of Motown, a lot of temptations.
Then my auntie is taking
it a little further
with the Funkadelic
and we getting some of that shit in there.
Then I'm down south and my cousins
they like literally this was down south
where they don't even
wear shoes in the summer.
It's just barefoot for summer
whole day, the fuck whatever.
- Real country.
- And you go into these
little candy shops, soda shops
but they also the fucking
bar where grownups hanging
the kids get to go to
this one little counter
buy some candy or a soda or
ice cream and get the fuck out.
But when you go in there,
they're playing the grammiest blue songs,
this shit is dark in the daytime.
This shit is like low-key as fuck.
And it's just those songs those
real dirt road, blues songs.
I always loved that shit.
So fast forward to like I'm
coming of age, I'm starting to,
I bought a lot of records as a kid too.
I spend a lot of my
candy money on records.
That was kind of weird, but I did it.
And I got to go to the George Clinton,
Parliament Funkadelic, 1976
mothership connection tour
in LA.
And that's the kind of tour,
where he landed the mothership
on the stage, jumped out.
I was just, I was 11, 12 years old.
I was about maybe I don't think I was 10.
And I'm like looking at this shit like
this mother fucker just
jumped out of stage.
And there were people on
that show that day, like
Rick James and shit it was
like a whole funk fest.
And I left that day.
I knew I loved music, but
I left that day like...
- That.
- Yeah, and that was, it
was just like, it never,
the stage, the music, the individual.
'Cause I always know how to
single out the bass player
or the drummer, the sound,
and at the saxophone.
I can just, I can study the sounds.
And I was never the same.
I was already barely a Parliament fan.
I was just getting into it.
It was by my second album in,
but I just my whole life was
just like the Funk after that,
just dissect.
- Tell him you played the drums too.
Let them know you played the drums.
- Yeah high school right?
- I was definitely in the marching band.
I was in the elementary school
band for a little while.
I kind of, you know, I just did,
I did enough in the band to
learn how to play instruments.
I fucked up when I got to 10th grade
and went to Fremont High and
I was cutting class too much.
And the band teacher came to me and said,
if I drop you from my class,
'cause you only got a certain
amount of days in Fremont.
If I drop you, you can
never take band ever again.
And I was, I didn't say it
but I was looking at him like,
fuck that nerd ass, fucking shit.
(indistinct)
(laughing)
Biggest mistake I ever made.
I should've stayed in band class.
- Let me ask you a questions.
Did you, 'cause what you
two were doing at the time
that you were doing it.
And I think about like what I saw happen
at Silicon Valley with social media apps.
I see it right now with cryptocurrency.
When you're at the beginning of something
there's always a moment
where you just doing it
'cause you're doing it.
And then you kind of realize,
wait, is this something big
like this is something
something's happening.
When did you realize
that was bigger than just your pursuit
of like you both were
passionate about music young.
When did you realize the genre
that you found yourself in?
Had the potential, I
mean, listen, Funk, Jack.
I mean the fact that I'm even
saying this blows my mind jazz
like hip hop is going to go down
has one of the most foundational
genres in music history.
If not, depends on, you know
I'm not looking real long,
classical rock, all of it.
It is such a big deal.
You guys have gotten to
such an iconic place.
You also came at a time where,
you know, I know enough about your career.
Like Short you're one
of the only people ever
Jay Z, Biggie, Pac to be
in, you know, in songs
with all three, like there's
you guys have done shit.
I actually wanna ask you
a separate question soon
which is like, when did you smile
when some young cat that you admired
and thought was gonna be
really good or became good,
came to you and said, you
really impacted my career,
but like two separate questions.
When did you know that it
was real, real, real big?
And that you'd be an old
man and have West coast
kind of on your shoulders
that you were gonna have that class
and B any fun stories of
somebody coming up the game
saying that you really influenced them
and you can't believe
how big their career got.
- For as so you're talking about
when somebody came up to me
or just-
- Yep I like stories.
I wanna hear a story of somebody
coming up to you and saying
E this song made me an artist
and that person now is this.
Because I think people don't
know history well enough.
And I know there's so many
young, you know, listeners.
I always love stories to
like put things into context.
- Yeah, this, I mean this from the streets
to the executive suites,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, there's so many youngsters
that (indistinct) like,
listen like we could take a look,
let's take a local in a minute.
'Cause this local really
is to us somebody,
he go by the name of, you know, J Style.
You know what I'm saying?
And he told me, he say, man, 40, you know
he said, you know, should
J be talking to her
he say, man, 40 man went
in a major way came out
I skip class blood, I
skip class to go get that.
I skip class, you know what I'm saying?
It's like this the thing
there's so many rappers that
really grew up on our music.
Not just mine, but Short as well.
And they'll tell you,
they'll simply tell you.
They will tell you so they
might not tell the world
but they'll tell you,
hey, if it wasn't for you,
I be fucked up in a street niggas
on the streets, in the trenches
on the octagon, on the
gravel on a black top.
Got tell you sincerely,
bro, thank you for the game.
Thank you.
Because if it wasn't for
you, you know what I'm saying
I don't know how I would've made it
whether they was doing
time behind them walls
or whatever the case may
be, 'cause that's all we do.
And to this day we were just
on the phone earlier, man,
Short, we said we got this one song,
or we ain't gonna say the cost
of what we was talking about.
You know, it's pretty much preaching
but it's not, no, it's not
it's not no preaching where
it's like too preaching.
We just, it's just a game.
And you can give to this,
you can give to it with (indistinct).
- (indistinct) a really fun hook.
And we're going to slide
a really powerful message
in this (indistinct).
- You know what I think
that's exactly right.
Like when I think about the ghetto short,
like you know, for me, it's
storytelling for me, right.
To me, it's storytelling.
What both of you represent for me
I'm talking from a single person
is I like when I can see the image,
it like plays like a movie in my head.
There, you know, I'm less around beat.
I know me as a consumer, like
people like upbeat is like
I understand, like I get it,
but it doesn't sink in me.
The artists that I really fuck with
are the ones that make me feel
like I'm watching a movie.
You know and especially that first album,
'cause you had your whole
life to fucking write it.
You know and you really
given me context of you.
Yeah that's it right.
- Pimp C once told me
that he said they were,
they sold the album cover to Born and Mac.
They had never heard of Too Short
and they had never heard the music.
They saw the album cover,
looked at it, held it and said
that's what I wanna do for a living.
Which is looking at
that drop tap Cadillac.
And then the little dude
sitting there with the jury, man
that I'm about to do some shit like that.
Like that should have
turned them the fuck out.
- And they did it.
- Something that really hit
me as a writer and a rapper
and a artists that just
was outside of the music.
A friend of mine went to jail
for a murder when he was 16.
And I was friends with his brother.
I didn't even really know him at the time
probably been around him, but
I'm more knew his big brother.
And he came home at the age of
maybe 40, 42 somewhere there.
And he said, one day he got me one-on-one
'cause as soon as he came home
he came amongst the friends I
was running with at the time.
And he's right there.
And he might wanna his first day at home
we took him to a Too Short concert
and he's like, holy shit.
And he said, and he got me one-on-one
he said, man, you know,
he said when I was down,
he said, I went to jail
when I was a kid, I was a child in 16.
He said, I literally lived my life.
I lived in Oakland through your songs.
Like he had no, he like, man, (indistinct)
'cause he is not the first person.
I'm Too Short.
And just visualize what I was saying
and got to be in Oakland
through the music.
So I, you know, it's things like that,
that make you realize the
impact that you're having.
Like somebody going,
man, I launched a career
just looking at album cover.
And somebody going, I
listened to your music
and got through my young
adult life in prison.
I got an outlet that I needed.
Like that shit is way
bigger than a hit record.
- Way bigger.
- Short have you ever
got tweets or comments
on your Instagram or Facebook
or social media anywhere?
And they say, I wish he was my dad.
- All that, all that like my
father, you are my father.
- They say it.
- Like they are saying their shit.
- Real quick, real quick.
Everybody is listening.
One of the reasons, the timing for this
these two have a double album out.
And I'm excited about it
because there's been a kid
that I've been really giving
love to for a long time
called Guapdad 4000 and they had him on.
And I'm about that kid.
I think he's real, real talent.
So a go check that out,
download stream album.
However you put some coins
in these man's pockets.
Talk to me about, versus talk
to me about entrepreneurship.
You know, 40, you know
I grew up in the liquor
and wine and spirits world, you know
immigrated from Russia, grew up in Queens.
My dad got a job as a stock
boy in a liquor store.
Eventually had his own small liquor store.
And I grew up in that place.
Merchant son, I worked 15 hours a day.
You've really gone heavy.
I look at your social
you got heavy into the spirits game.
I wanna get a little bit of that.
I really wanna know how
the first experience was
just for you like the enjoyment,
some fun stories about
it, how you feel it went.
And you wanna talk to each other
wherever you guys wanna take it.
- Hey you know, I'm gonna
tell you something, man.
You know, my granddaddy
used to always say,
he said I've been in the car with him.
'Cause you know, I had a
paper route when I was young.
I, you know what I'm saying
with my granddaddy and
granddaddy was granddad's paper
but he'll pick me up and
he'd say, he'd look at me
'cause I was ever quiet,
but I was always observing
and would not soak up
game like a beach tab.
And then one day he just a
boy, cause I was hella quiet.
Just me and him in the car.
He just, you're heavy thinker huh.
I say, yeah, granddaddy
I have my, you know, as I grew older
I became a heavy thinker,
but also a heavy drinker.
He knows it I'm not an alcoholic.
I'm just a serious social drinker.
So be saying that, you know,
moms, you know what I'm saying
She loved drinking.
Like she drink, you know,
scotch, all that stuff.
But that wasn't a thing.
It was really, you know like why,
'cause my mom worked two or three jobs.
She worked at the little
store around the corner.
She worked at Napa State hospital.
You understand me?
We used to watch walls on Mare Island.
You know, people, a lot of
kids don't know washing walls
is to prevent paint
having to paint your walls
you wash them. You know so
we used to have to do that.
You know, as a kid on the weekends
she had so many jobs, Merck
worked at Maggie's Hamburgers.
I used to throw salt on the floor,
you know, after I mopped
I used to be in the back of
a little kid, little young.
So like 13 years old back there mopping
you know what I'm saying
or whatever and you know,
and so on and so forth.
So anyway, she would
come home on a Friday.
- Actually can I interrupt
you 'cause I know my audits
Short, 40.
How much do you think work
ethic played into your success?
- That's what did it for me,
'cause my mama, like I said-
- 95%.
- 95% 'cause I was the oldest of four.
- 'Cause I'm listening to you
and like, you know, it's speaking to me
'cause it's I had a
very similar childhood,
like you know, shoveling,
like it's snowing like crazy right here
in New York right now I looked outside.
I'd be like, I'd be ringing
door while everybody's sledding.
I'd be ringing doorbells
'cause my parents weren't giving me money.
- Come on, man.
I've worked at Mickey D's.
I got, I've worked at Mickey D's.
I worked at, you know what I'm saying
I have, I worked at Valero
neighborhood housing paint wall.
- Look 'cause I think
this will help people.
I'm sorry to interrupt.
You went through,
you guys have gone through
iconic music, careers.
I'm sure when I say to you think right now
about kids that you saw
come through in studio
or writing who were talented as fuck
but they didn't have the work ethic
and you knew they had more talent
but nobody knows who they are Short.
- Now you know, in this game, man
if you hang around long
enough, you instantly know
that success does not
come to the talented.
It does not like, that's
a gift you get talent.
It's people who can
surpass your talent and ask
just by mimicking talent.
They don't have it.
They just could pretend it.
But they put a hustle with
it and they fuck you like,
how's this guy he's clearly
not as good as this guy.
How did he get up there?
He fuck hit them right fuck spots.
And he fucking did that shit.
So it's like, I just know, man,
like you talk about your hustle.
My hustle was always like to,
to be productive every day.
So it's like, I'm gonna wake
up as a child, as a teenager
as an adult and whatever fuck
I'm doing when I wake up,
I'm about to do a whole lot
of shit to add to that today.
Like it might be one thing.
It might be 10 things.
I'm going out there.
If I'm a kid I'm leaving home, I'm going
I'm getting active.
I'm going to play a sport.
I'm going to fucking-
- You were constantly in motion.
- Yeah when I'm fucking 44.
- And Short, exotic pop.
Right I see you promote like
do you bring the same energy to,
like is that a partnership
you have ownership?
What's the story with that?
- I'm doing just a line of soda with them.
I mean, when you get to
this point in the game
I have not had to think about, you know,
like little hustles and shit.
It's just shit stays on the plate.
The shit don't, you get
paid for the legacy, man,
you know what I mean.
I'm making use of my
brain I don't have to.
- The way you carried
himself so many years
when you solid it and you just, you know
you got a great reputation,
you help other people out.
He's like, I'm not
gonna put myself in this
but this is a way to say me
and me and him do the same shit
we fuck with the young generation.
We rock with them, they rock
with us we rock with them.
- Which I love.
- All those opportunities come to you.
So that being said,
what you was asking me?
Well, how did I start getting
into, adult beverages,
drinking wine, my mama drank wine.
I sneak in her wine every
now and then (indistinct).
- Like the gallon, the big gallon.
- (indistinct) you know what am saying.
- I know Carlo Rossi that same as,
I was skinny.
That was heavy for me.
Those four liters, four
of them in that big box
that was worse.
- Gallo is who influenced me just by,
just Gallo the whole story,
how they started as family.
You know what I'm saying.
I got nothing but love for Gallo.
Now I had my own thing going,
you know what I'm saying.
I'm not never trying to compete with them.
I just want a small (indistinct).
- It's not a piece for a little 40.
- I love it there yeah
'cause they the ones,
you know what I'm saying.
So anyway.
- What's your favorite?
You've got so many for you personally.
- I mean I don't know if y'all can see it,
but this is my number one seller.
This right here is called
mangoscatto and they go crazy.
- My thing my favorite social,
literally some of my
favorite social media posts
in the world. And this
is what I do for a living
is when you're taking
photos of huge stacks
and random liquor stores.
'Cause it takes me back to me.
I love it, I love-
- He stayed stacks, he mean
cases like cases of liquor.
- This places liquor stores,
where I know the owner
just wanted to meet 40.
So he put 40 stacks on the ground
'cause he wanted that photo.
- You know, I went from
wine to selling cognac.
This is tycoon.
- Tycoon yep.
- This one you know what I'm saying.
This is the word that I been
screaming for many years.
You know, I probably first
displayed it in like 1995
in a major way to intro to in a major way
My tycoon partner, player
partners or whatever I said,
you know what I'm saying.
But I've been saying it
for many moons way before
whoever you think made it up
I made it up.
- 40 before I let you go
'cause I'm gonna be mad at myself.
'cause I blank a lot.
- Yeah (indistinct) so this is Coca-Cola.
Hold on let me put it in the
screen. Let me back it up.
This is Cola flavor.
- Back it up.
- Coca-Cola Coca-Cola got the old thing.
- I need to know where your mind was-
- Cola flavor.
(indistinct)
- Listen, do your 40 I'm about it.
Talk to me about, hold
on, hold on, hold on
I need to get this question in.
I need to know when your
head was Sprinkle Me Suga T.
I need to know it's a fucking banger.
I need to know.
- You need to know.
Okay so check this out are you ready?
- Yeah.
- All right there you go.
- Give me some game.
- I'm gonna give you some
games. So my sister Suga T,
you know she was raised around
us three boys, me, D-Shot
and Mugsy and B-Legit and
all just all just hogs.
We all hogs.
I don't know if y'all know what hogs mean,
but that's an OG word for like a beef,
like, you know, monsters
like before from a sucker,
you know what I'm saying.
So she raised around real ones.
You know what I'm saying.
So she connected with, you know,
she was enthused, she loved folk that
you know what I'm saying this game done.
So she ran across my OG
partner, which I love
I got nothing but love for to this day.
He go by the name of James Bradley.
Still I call him, OG stumped down.
Right one thing he did
around around us, you know
he would have on Thanksgiving
the whole world we are real folks
the OG though, he all, he older than me.
You know what I'm saying.
And so he was like, you know, fuck man
and I like to sprinkle the kids.
I like, you know, not
sprinkled let me not over.
It's like really just
really just gaming them up,
license, number another word for license.
But he say, sprinkled me.
You know what I'm saying.
So one day me and Suga T in the studio,
we have no idea that
we're gonna make a song
called Sprinkle Me.
What Mike Mosley and Sail Boston.
We in Fairfield, California,
right next door to them.
I think McDonald's,
McDonald's or somewhere
we have (indistinct) Fairfield studio.
And so we, so they made the beat
and Mike Mosley kept hauling (indistinct).
I was like huh.
♪ Tamu tamu slaty water ♪
♪ Sprinkle me Mike ♪
You know, this was my focus was saying,
man, like that Sprinkle Me, man.
So anyway, that just came
naturally because the Sprinkle Me
that was in my head, he was right there.
So she made it official
because that was her boyfriend
at the time.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, you know, it just happened.
So we connected and did it.
And it became a major hit
that we wasn't expecting.
To hit could come out of nowhere.
Like a contractual hit on your head, bro.
I'm telling you, that's how his coat.
That's how it is, it's
not a hit, not clan.
It's not playing like that for us.
I mean, for us, the element of surprise.
That's what a hit is.
It's the element of surprise, bro.
They come out of nowhere
and that's what happens
- Actually Short I wan to know,
what surprised the shit
out of you for you?
And what cause I think this helps a lot.
We have a lot of youngsters
who are in music,
listen to this.
What hit surprise you,
you didn't expect it,
And what song did you just fucking believe
you hit up your man 40, you
hit up everybody around.
You're like, wait till this
comes out, but it didn't go.
It didn't go you fucking believed
you thought it was gonna be hit.
I'm just curious about
when I asked you that,
does anything stand out?
- On second part, man.
I'm really, I don't have
like, like your kids
if you had a bunch of kids,
I really don't have expectations.
I don't believe early on,
I started getting hit records
without expecting that.
So I'm like Too Short these
records are going big.
And I was, I was happy with
like reasonable success
and they just went big, big, big.
So that was like I'm 20
years old, 21 years old.
And it just that every, since then
records would come along
getting in cocktails.
These records was just do what they do.
And I kind of, I had a career
where my underground songs
can rival the radio songs,
like in terms of popularity.
- 100%.
- And driving sales.
So I would do concerts with other artists
and they might not want
him to sign they be like,
I know that dude had that one song.
I see his video on Yellow
MTV, but then I'm singing
15 other songs they're
like, who fuck is this?
- And the crowd, and the crowd knew it.
It was crazy.
It was kind of like, you
know, it had that early.
It's like an earlier
version of mixed tapes.
- So I have a song that is
called Gangsters and Strippers.
And this song, if you never heard it
it would make you like it.
And you would get a reaction.
It gets a reaction out of everybody
because the first line of the song is,
"I gotta get a bitch
and get my dick sucked."
And I repeat it.
I repeat that four times
before I even bust one bar.
♪ I gotta get a bitch
and get my dick sucked ♪
and get ♪ Four times. ♪
And now, no matter who's in
the crowd, I got an old lady.
I got the old lady she's like,
is he fucking saying this?
Like if you can't not have a reaction,
so the beat comes on it's infectious.
Never got a radio spin,
never did a video to it.
I didn't even give a fuck about the song.
- Iconic, it was awesome.
- I did not give two
fucks about this song.
And when MTV had this
show called "Sweet 16,"
and these teenagers were
having these sweet 16 parties
extravagant parties
people around the Bay and different places
really around the Bay a
lot were doing these mimic
in these MTV parties and
giving their kids Mercedes
for their birthday and having
these big expensive parties.
But it wasn't on the TV show.
- Short I literally, I don't know
if you're not gonna be able to see it.
I have a very, very, very
subtle scar on my pinky.
It's because me and my man moves
used to drive around campus.
And when the line I'm too
short reach on the ladies'
pimp would come on I would
punch my steering wheel
because I would get so hyped.
One time I cut it so bad.
It's just so your voice is also super like
I don't know, this is just
such a pleasure because.
- These suburb kids upper class.
They actually was, they meet at the party
in the San Ramon Danville.
And these fucking, these kids
asked me to play this song
that I was like, why
would they want that song?
They are kids like, it's the dirtiest song
in the fucking world.
I don't even known that song.
And the kids asked for one specific song,
Gangsters and Strippers.
I sing this song for these teenagers.
And the whole damn room
knows the song word for word.
And I'm like interesting, 20
something years into my career.
So I started experimenting with this song
that these one little group
of teenagers asked me to play
and everywhere I go,
everybody know the words.
I'm like when and where
and how did this fucking song become this?
And I don't fucking,(indistinct).
- It's real legend shit.
Like, you know, you've got
these contemporary artists.
Who've got a lot.
Like I always like when Saweetie
samples you the other day
like I hear it for the first time.
I'm like, I wonder if
people that are 20 know
the genius of this, you know
like I always think about, you know,
this is what's fun about being 45 now,
you know enough about the lineage
and you see the recall and you know,
when you have that kind of ebbs and flows
and it's just phenomenal.
What are you guys thinking
about going forward?
40 what's your mind on these days?
How do you think about 2021?
- Let me just say this,
this, you know, Twitter
Twitter crack me up
'cause Twitter is Twitter
Twitter no fool.
- Twitter is not defeated.
- Twitter play no games.
Twitter people kept telling me saying,
I see someone on TikTok they
say 40, a one hit wonder.
Right and they just
scratching my head with a fuck
who the fuck was they born in?
What rock was they living under?
You know what I'm saying?
It's like, you never know that.
And I'm tell you the one hit
wonder, they said Choices.
Choices yeah.
- That's a youngster.
- Yeah that's a youngster, he
had to be like five 12 or 14
15, maybe younger, maybe older,
but he thought choices yeah.
He thought that was my
only hit that I ever had
out of my 33 year career.
32 years, 32, 32 years, 1988, 32.
I'll be I forget anyway.
- Little ass kid knows E-40
knows all your songs
that's as amazing for you.
- Well was good enough,
and I didn't get mad.
I don't even know who the kid is.
- And some little kids were
making a dance routine up
to blow the whistle and not near
one of them mother could
have been as old as the song.
- A 100%.
And that's, that's the beauty of getting
into that classic zone and still doing it
and still having your
interests in different places.
Where are you in social media and YouTube.
What do you fuck with?
What are you confused by?
What do you like?
What do you use?
- I love (indistinct).
I was a master E-40 he's a master.
But me, I'm a realist.
And I live with the
reality that we believe
that we use these tools in certain ways
but this is using us.
It's pepper that's for real.
(indistinct)
I'm just saying, I'm not talking about
the way you can milk media and make money.
I'm talking about what you give to it
and what it gets from you,
that's what's am talking about.
- That's very true.
I just had to clarify,
I'm right with you Pepe.
You know what I'm saying?
But I understand what you're saying.
Hey, but I'm saying how, you know,
my folks are ain't involved in
the shit that Jeff stemmed me
that they think is peppering.
You know what I'm saying?
- Back door investment (indistinct).
- By the way, by the way (indistinct).
Hello everybody.
There is always give and take.
- You know what am saying.
- Of course I will am
so glad you are here.
Your entire career has been
give and take though Short.
Right there's always a platform.
There's always someone in your pockets.
There's always a venue
that has the attention.
There's always a platform.
What's beautiful about this is,
what you're able to do by building demand.
You know, there's no gatekeepers.
Somebody was the gatekeeper of it.
Yo MTV raps, and decided
here it's direct to consumer.
That should matter 40 take it away.
- So here's the deal.
We nowadays, a lot of our
I would say our culture, hip hop as well.
You know, this is our culture.
I've been on this page from day one.
That was a young moustache
like entrepreneur.
I've been on that page
the ownership independent, all that shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Now it's the new sexy to be
independent, to own shit.
You know what I'm saying?
This that, and the third that's good.
So you work your way
you climb your way up
the ladder, you know.
'Cause you know us, first
of all, you understand
that as an African-American,
you know we were stopped
in the middle of arch.
We couldn't, they didn't
want us to learn how to read
or write or nothing, bro.
So we making like coins
and doing some catching up
and we're doing pretty good.
You know what I'm saying.
To be held back from like
you get your fucking boss
cut off and like that.
Hung and all kinds of shit.
If you get caught learning how to read.
Come on, man what kind of is that?
So all I'm saying is we
are making great progress
as our people.
You know what I'm saying.
So I try to have I try to
support all black businesses
and this ain't no no like
we, I'm far from racist,
you know what I'm saying.
I love humans.
I love people.
- I think that's beautiful.
I think like I laugh when people get upset
like that's what people do.
That's why, you know, Polish
people support poli right
like Jewish people support Jewish.
That's a good thing.
Why is that bad?
- Especially when you had as bad as us
and nobody's had it bad,
but I'm saying, you know, we
got to start looking into us
like bro we all on the same team
has enough money out there for everybody,
let's get this bread.
- Abundance, once you start
realizing there's abundance
you can really do something.
- Definitely so, you know, you
got people in the background
that's in social media, on the tuck
that people don't realize
that's in the background
of somebody's social media companies
that has part of that.
You know what I'm saying.
And it ain't, I'm not just saying me,
you know I'm in there too.
You know what I'm saying.
I just don't scream everything.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't say I'll tell everything,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, you wouldn't never think
that E-40 isn't 50 startup companies
you know what I'm saying?
You would never think that
you might not even know.
'Cause a lot of people don't know.
They don't know very smart.
I've sharpened, sharpening
a porcupine spot.
I'm very sharp, I'm just calm.
I'm just like a personality.
I'm like, oh, what makes the best rapper?
Too Short.
You one of the greatest
rappers of all time,
not because of what you stand for,
what you spit the game that you spit
but you bring humor to the game.
We bring humor to the
real life situations.
How about that?
That'll make the dopest rapper.
- By the way, Short brings
humor to difficult situations.
I look, you know, when I
listened to Short as a kid,
you can imagine I, and I didn't
grow up in a wealthy area,
so I didn't have that.
But I just still had people
like Short is fucking crazy.
Like Short was bringing
real, crazy lyrics.
You know, and like whoever
heard it, a friend's mom
the neighbor like a teacher
like it was real, real, real aggressive.
And I remember, you know,
thinking about the judgment
because I was very, you know
I was born in Russia where Jewish
was kind of like black in America, right.
Both my grandfather
spent real time in jail
just for being Jewish.
Antisemitism is crazy in Europe.
Not like we don't have that in US.
This is more of a race country.
But I remember thinking
you're making judgment
on this dude and all the
music I was listening to.
I'm like, but you don't
know, this is like an escape.
Like the humorous, like you
people use humor to cope.
Short was putting out humor
about like situations.
What's up brother?
- Nancy Reagan's suck
my mother fucker dick.
- Exactly and like now (indistinct).
- (indistinct) the president,
motherfucker was like,
you can put that shit out?
- And what people.
- Let me go back to my teenage days.
Drop it down like it was what.
(laughs)
Like it was what?
- One of the mother fuckers.
- Listen people in
revisionary history understand
at the time like people, you know
now we have the 40 years of retrospective
of like drug laws and
things of that nature.
This is why art, listen,
you guys are artists.
I always tell people.
I'm like you've got to take a step back.
You're coming from a very narrow angle
and a lot of these conversations.
Take a step back
- Do you remember when
they was steam rolling
hip hop cassette tapes.
- Of course.
(indistinct)
Of course I do.
- Started working in (indistinct).
- Of course, I mean.
- Do you know once in the history
of any of this should
anybody ever dropped my name
in any of those, we have a problem
with this list of artists.
- Why?
- He had the nastiest mouth of all time.
- Why Short?
I don't know why.
Do you have a sense.
- For the most part
I would think the main ingredient was that
I was not a mainstream artists,
even though I had mainstream numbers.
They were listening to all these
artists who have publicists
and who were blasting and were selling.
They were actually
marketing their controversy.
I was just doing it.
If we didn't Joe, the job
didn't have to market Too Short.
And they didn't have to
market the image of Too Short
or E-40 none of us, they
we really were spicy one.
UTK even talked about carer as one
we all marketed ourselves
and John records, you know, they just,
all they had to do is
put the machine to work
to get it in the right outlets.
We were fucking phenomenal artists.
- Why they signed us
to distribution deals.
And so on and so forth,
we had built in fan base.
Our fan base is so loyal (indistinct).
- With a high five.
- What is that you said John has signed
compared him to the artists
that Def Jan had signed
at the same time.
The Def jam artists are huge.
They got this marketing tactic
where they're everything is.
they pushing them everywhere.
Fucking make a video everywhere.
John is fucking artists are like timeless.
It's on careless one.
E-40 fucking missed Too Short.
You know what I'm saying
fucking a trap cop class.
I'm talking fucking UGK.
Like they have a roster
that stands timeless.
- What is Leon too.
(indistinct)
Listen, I could do this all day.
I gotta rap.
Gimme a little gift.
Give some game to these youngsters.
What's your parting shots legends?
- I've got one.
That's what a game is
that this is like you got
this is a chance for you to get
what you got four legendary.
- You know about Westmore.
(indistinct)
- Man Westmore is a you
could call it a supergroup.
That I'm fine with that.
But man Westmore is a corporation.
It's an LLC form by the way.
- This is the Snoop and ice cube, right?
Yeah I got you.
I got you I know what you guys are doing.
- Basically, we've started
off making a few songs.
We were like four very intelligent guys
who didn't take 10 seconds
into the venture to go,
well, let's license this let's branch out.
Let's do this deal.
And it shipped turns into a
multi fucking million
dollar deal instantly
just for joining forests and.
- Called leverage.
You guys fucking avenger that thing.
- Hey, listen, bro.
They're the Avengers in real life.
- That's cool I mean.
- Know the super friends (indistinct).
- That's right the rings and shit.
- It's like, you know, you got
four some of your favorite rappers
four some of your favorite
iconic rappers, especially.
And we from the coast, we always was us.
Each individual, all our
voices poke out like nipples,
Snoop Dog. You ain't
even got to see his face.
Oh, that's Snoop rapper, Too Short.
Oh, you ain't got to even see
his face. That's Too Short,
Ice Cube.
Oh that's Ice Cube rapping.
E-40, you know I poke out like nipples,
that what all of us do.
You know what I'm saying?
You got some of the coldest rappers
and you got two of them from
up top Northern California,
(indistinct) they just might be here.
You understand me from
Southern California.
You understand me what
to do some harm to you.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's like, you got all these
great rappers, four of them
and we all get along
and (indistinct) people.
- Prior to coming together,
we're already for years,
probably the past 18 years
we've been doing all
these West coast festivals
every fucking two three times a year.
We have them out in the
Midwest and proceed.
- (indistinct) like OG music.
So that's why he, that's fine.
Just like he said, 10 years,
like the last 10 years
it's just been like, it's been, you know
at one time they stopped
saying this Too Short,
listen I'm gonna say this.
They stopped saying this.
They stopped saying, ah man,
he 40 years old, why he rapping
they don't do that no more.
(indistinct) 40 real quick.
- Real quick.
- You feel me so they don't
say that shit no more.
- 40 it's a young genre you know.
You know, when I look at all
y'all now I'm like, oh shit.
'Cause when I was a teenager,
I'm like, yo these parents
really fuck with the rolling stones still.
And they get, and they get crunk.
Like when they go out, like
parents would come back
from rolling stones, giant stadium.
I'd be like, yo, they've
really threw down tonight.
And that's what's happened
and now I understand it
because that was a young
genre rock and roll
hip hop came 30 20 years
or whatever the math is,
34 years and is the same shit now.
- That's what we say, Gary.
We say, why rockers can do it all day.
They can rock all day.
How come rappers can't rap off all day.
- They just came a little earlier.
Listen, I can't wait to be
80 being in a little lounge
hear you guys spit some poems.
- So the future is we did
not do an album together.
We recorded about 40, 50 songs.
And this is going to
be a continuous thing.
It's gonna be a volume
one, two, three, four
five type of situation.
They're probably gonna
come out pretty quick.
- It's not just one album is many of them.
And we got a blast and we,
what we doing is exactly
what y'all think we doing.
We got that happy medium.
You know, we gonna want, y'all want
y'all gonna want to hear some songs
where it's like the sound
that y'all grew up on.
Just like when I listened to earth 105,
a dang I don't wanna do
no new scores I could find
even when if I need them
to have that happy medium earth 105.
But we got that new school too.
'Cause you understand me.
We rock with the new school too.
So we got them.
We're not going overboard with it.
You feel what I'm saying?
Hell off.
- So the partnerships,
the, you know, the merge
the license of the image
wherever it may go to move
the tours we build for you.
- I cheer for you, sir.
- Give me a call four different managers
and book us on a tour.
You gotta call us now from now on.
- I love it good for you, fellas.
I appreciate your time.
I cheer for you heavy.
Keep pushing it.
Keeps showing all the labels.
Let them circle them.
Short, 40 thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
Helping and happiness hit me anytime.
Anything I can help you with.
- God bless you, thank you for everything.
- Of course, see you soon.
- Bye bye.
YouTube watchers what's up it's Gary Vee,
first of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to
explode stories, polls
more content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.